(أهلا بالموت)
جملة كانت هي الرد من عبدالغني عبدالغفور
، عندما سمع نطق الحكم عليه بالإعدام،
اهلا با الموت من اجل العراق والإسلام والعروبة
من احكام المادة 406 على 1
يسقط الاحتلال الأمريكي
يسقط الاحتلال الفارسي
يسقط الاحتلال &&&&&
شخصية قوية من أتباع صدام حسين،
لم يهب الموت،
ولم يخف من سجانيه، فقد رباهم صدام على العزة والشموخ،
في الوقت الذي يطلب فيه الناس العفو، ويتذللون عند حكم الإعدام،
قال هو (اللهم اجعلني شهيدا في سبيلك)...
(فمن هو عبدالغني عبدالغفور؟، ولم حكم عليه بالإعدام؟)
عبد الغني عبد الغفور فليح آل مدلج العاني سياسي عراقي،
انتمى إلى حزب البعث العربي الاشتراكي عام 1958
وبعد انقلاب 17 يوليو - تموز عام 1968
تقلد العديد من المناصب الحكومية والسياسية والحزبية منها:
مدير عام الثقافة الجماهيرية في وزارة الاعلام العراقية
ثم أصبح وزيرا للأوقاف، ثم وزيرا للثقافة والإعلام،
وكان عضوا بارزا في مجلس قيادة الثورة حتى عام ٢٠٠١،
اعتقل بعد الغزو الأمريكي للعراق عام 2003 ،
وأودع في معتقل كروبر الأمريكي قرب مطار بغداد.
ثم أحيل إلى المحكمة الجنائية العراقية العليا
التي حكمت عليه بحكمين الحكم الأول كان  الإعدام
(فردد عباراته الشهيرة أهلا بالموت ، اللهم اجعلني شهيدا في سبيلك )
فتراجع الجلاد عن حكمه لكي لا يصل عبد الغني مبتغاه )
فاصدروا حكما آخر  بسجنه مدى الحياة،
لم يخف ويستكين، بل ظهر جسورا شجاعا كقائده صدام حسين،
وهو ما جعله أحد رموز المقاومة العراقية ضد الاحتلال،
عندها توقف المحتل عن تنفيذ الحكم الإعدام،
وظل سجينا لديهم، كأي أسير حرب لكن وبعد قرابة ٥ سنوات،
تم تسليمه إلى السلطات العراقية في العام 2008
وأودع في سجن الكاظمية، وإذ  بالحكومة العراقية
تعامله أسوأ من المعاملة التي تلقاها من المحتل الأمريكي،،،
فنقل في عام 2012 إلى سجن الناصرية
مع المسؤولين العراقيين السابقين .
وهناك أضرب عن تعاطي الأدوية الخاصة بالأمراض المزمنة التي لديه،
فماذا كان رد الحكومة العراقية،
. لم يفعلوا شيئا لأجل هذا البطل الذي رحب بالموت،
ولم يجدّ أي جديد في قضيته بتعاقب الحكومات في السلطة العراقية،
ولايزال عبدالغني رهين الاعتقال في السجن ويعاني من الامراض
والشيخوخة وهناك جدل حول مصيره .
لم يعد هناك فرق بين القادة العرب و المحتلين،
فالقادة أصبحوا أدوات للغرب الذي لم يعد بحاجة لجيوشه للسيطرة على العرب،،،
ومن وقف ضدهم فمصيره كمصير عبدالغني عبدالغفور،
فمتى تصحو الشعوب العربية من غفلتها؟